hello boys and girls ladies and gents
this is tim ferriss and i'm going to
answer a question about
covid or postcovid
life and navigation thereof this is
responding to a question
that i received which is what tim thinks
we should be prepared for in a world
with covet
what jobs will be most needed what kinds
of companies will experience most growth
what will the new paradigms be and how
should we adapt to them
and should we be prepared to wear masks
forever
so i i laugh about the last part not
because it's funny but because
the short answer to that is no you won't
have to wear masks forever because
humans won't do it
there already is mutiny and there will
be certainly more mutiny
eventually we'll have to find
workarounds but
one approach to answer the rest of this
question would be to go bullet by bullet
and try to give you my predictions
i think those predictions could prove
completely false
or inaccurate there are a few i think
are reasonably on point at least in the
short term which would be
accelerated growth of companies that are
distributed or have distributed
capabilities that are
involved with e-commerce so i'm an
investor in shopify
amazon etc i don't necessarily recommend
you invest in those this is not
investment advice but
i feel fairly confident that those
trends
which were inevitable to begin with are
accelerating certainly if you model them
after comparables like china but i'm not
going to answer this question
in that fashion because i don't think
that those are the most helpful
answers to give what i want to suggest
is that
in a world with covid and i don't think
covet is going anywhere
we're going to have many new strains and
people talk about
the handful of strains thus far that
have been identified say in south africa
and elsewhere
but those are just the places where
they've happened to sequence these
strains they exist elsewhere
so the question really is how do we cope
and my suggestion is my recommendation
is that you put your own
oxygen mask on first before helping
others
metaphorically speaking and practically
speaking
all that means is unless you can take
care of yourself
you're not going to be able to take care
of your family and you're certainly not
going to be able to save anyone else
there are a million recommendations i
could give most of them are going to be
related to self-care
exercise diet etc i'm not going to
belabor those i'm going to give you two
perhaps
you haven't heard discussed quite as
much so the first is make plans
actually make plans what would you do
over the next 6 months
12 months consider traveling consider
doing all the things you would like to
do not because you can do them
but because there is value in the
planning it's going to force you to
think about
vaccines it's going to force you to
think about risks it's going to force
you to think about
logistics and this is to say
while your plans may end up worthless
there will still be tremendous value in
the planning
this is really important i think to
underscore and understand
that most plans do not survive first
contact with a customer with reality
with a punch in the face
but the active planning forces you to
ask questions and consider things
perhaps you wouldn't have come across
otherwise and there's a lot of value in
that so plan out the next 12 months
and consider different adventures
consider how you could make them work
and it's also going to be uplifting to
have something to even tentatively look
forward to
so i suggest doing this and the last is
control your information intake
i think over the last year it has become
a national and global sport to doom
scroll
that is to constantly look through
social media
and elsewhere at text from your friends
for all the worst things that have
happened today
anywhere in the world or especially
somewhere close to you
this is really unhelpful and
damaging in more respects than i can
even name
but suffice to say if it's not relevant
to your life if you're not going to
take action based on this new
information if it's not going to change
your behavior
if you can't affect some change if
you're not going to try to help
don't pay attention to it there's no
value
there is no value in unless we consider
the value to be
putting you in a terrible mood and
putting a dark lens over everything else
that you see that day
these technologies or at least the
content and the content providers are
very often incentivized
to make you as incensed or afraid or
angry as possible
i don't think that contributes to your
productivity or well-being so
really get your doom scrolling under
control consider deleting your social
media apps from your phone which is what
i have done
and i feel that that will provide
tremendous dividends and roi
in your life in a world with or without
covid
you